what do you think about when you hear
about what happened in Hawaii where they
get this message people living in Hawaii
that missiles are on the way and then it
turns out to be a mistake yeah how did
you react to that Oh again
scared the hell out of me and you know
and I love Hawaii I have our friends
there but you know who freaked out not
the Native Hawaiians no because the
natives they don't have a freakout zone
right they don't they don't even know
what that that is they don't live in
Hawaii regularly they didn't say those
people who were born Hawaiians they
don't they don't have a freakout zone
right you know it's like oh we ran out
of pig oh yeah did you talk to friends I
have a good friend there yeah and I
called her and for his first I texted I
was okay no everything is probably all
jammed up and then I finally heard from
her and I thought you okay well you
freaked out when she said and she goes
what happened so not only did she sleep
through it none of her neighbors
bothered to wake her up and go girl you
better go but then they just over there
there Joe there Joe they're very chill I
love Hawaii go there a lot yes
you